[Music]
Kate Middleton is unnatural with kids so
it's no surprise she seems to have the
whole mom thing down with her three
kiddos George Charlotte and Louie cases
you know she's very broody now et is
taking a look back at her cutest mommy
moments since first giving birth six
years ago it's only fitting that we
start with her postpartum photo call
with a newborn Prince George the Duchess
of Cambridge was a radiant vision as she
hit the steps of the Lindo wing at Saint
Mary's Hospital with hubby Prince
William and their firstborn son royal
watchers couldn't get over her perfect
blowout that giant smile and her
effortlessly chic blue and white polka
dot Jenny Packham dress but it's Kate's
still ever-present bump on full display
that really made fans feel that she's
just like us at number six the way Kate
expertly parented George and Charlotte
on their first ever royal tours there
were lots of adorable photo ops and
waves several near meltdowns and this
too cute for words garden party where
Kate played with her little ones who
doesn't love a good bubble moment then
came Will and Kate's third child Prince
Louie but now one year old royal made
his trooping the colors debut last May
and let's just say the drama was real
Louie had his famous mama cracking up
and we couldn't help but laugh along
with her and if you think that's cute
you'll love our number-4 moment
featuring Kate and Louise play date with
Megan Markel and her son Archie not only
did Louie run away while watching his
Papa Prince William and uncle Prince
Harry play polo
he also adorably rocked a pair of shades
this child definitely has personality
then again it seems like all the
Cambridge kiddos do and something tells
us they have their mom to thank for that
at number three the time Kate built a
garden fit for well a prince last spring
the Duchess teamed up with landscape
architects to
the playful woodland oasis inspired by
childhood memories for the Chelsea
Flower Show her message to inspire
families to get outside and enjoy nature
the experiences we gained during August
yes Kate's own kids served as the guinea
pigs before the gardens grand opening
and just in case the pigs didn't speak
volumes about how the Cambridge kids
felt Prince George gave Kate's project
his stamp of approval how many moms so
tell me together attending the hottest
20 out of 10 that's pretty good I think
me so well another favorite happened on
Christmas morning when George and
Charlotte joined Will and Kate for their
very first public walk to Christmas
service the foursome walked hand-in-hand
and when Kate pulled her daughter aside
to meet some well-wishers our hearts
completely exploded
it's very special having them even go to
the family and for our all-time favorite
moment
the mom of three unable to hold back
laughter as Charlotte sticks out her
tongue at photographers and fans the
hilarious moment happened at the King's
Cup Regatta in August and we could
literally watch it all day
[Music]